but if you don't get my attention it
doesn't matter how good your product or
service is because i'm just
i'm just not there
[Music]
linda popke thank you for joining me how
are you
i'm great how are you michael wonderful
you're in
redwood city the air is not the best
right now because there's fires
happening today
right no it's smoky out there but we're
staying inside
we're staying inside anyway so it
doesn't really it doesn't really matter
but hopefully by the time this airs the
fires will of course have
have gone out and hopefully cover will
be a little bit better as well
and i have to start with your fun fact
because you played the same piano that
billy joel played
i actually played the uh the the concert
grand piano that billy joel
bought uh and that's why i'm a classical
pianist i do that for
um for fun and to to kind of keep me
sane
and i was in new york a number of years
ago and
was at the steinway store um in uh
not far from from carnegie hall and we
were knowing one of the reps were
playing a number of the pianos and then
she says try this one down here and had
a tag on it said joel
oh who's joel do you like that i said
yeah joel's got a nice piano
so do you know who that is i said no she
said billy joel so
he had tagged that piano he bought it
and we played it before he even got in
his house
so so i i really hope that you didn't
wash your hands
since that moment because i know that i
i wouldn't for the rest of my life he's
one of my favorite artists of all time
so when i saw that fun fact
i was i was blown away but that that's
just that's that's wonderful
linda i i want to transition to
marketing and
consulting two two really um interesting
things that i know very very little
about so i'm especially curious for the
for this episode and i'd love to start
by talking a little bit about
uh the role of messaging and marketing
and your
ability to help other entrepreneurs
managers executives
convey their message in a way that helps
them you know at the end
when and whether it's sales or or
bringing the right people on board
or just getting the right messaging
across and then we'll transition to the
organization that we're helping run
the sac for consulting so let's start
off linda talk to me a little bit about
yourself your journey
and why marketing what is it about
marketing that that really
makes you excited so it's funny because
i guess i
i don't think i ever consciously said i
want to be a marketer but
uh i'm creative and i like to um i've
always been a writer
and it just seemed to be a great way to
kind of get get things across
and i started out actually wanting to be
a journalist and i went to uh
boston university to the school of
public communications and
you know they had us write things like
obituaries and follow town council
meetings and all that stuff and i said
this is boring
you know um this is not going to be the
fun stuff you see on tv and in the
movies
so i said what can i do that would be a
little more interesting and i sort of
wound up in advertising in pr
and then from there into into really
marketing and i think with me what's fun
is you have people like yourself you
have people who are entrepreneurs
they have a wonderful product they have
a great idea they really
are passionate about it but no matter
how good that is if you can't translate
that
into something that your audience cares
about it doesn't matter
so we sort of have this i i've got this
great product this great idea
we're going to be successful that's not
always true
a lot of too many really good ideas just
fall by the wayside
right because we haven't been able to
get the right message to the right
person
and it's not just having saying in
general what's good about you but
why do i care if i'm your audience why
is that important to me
it's not important because you're good
or because you're smarter because you
have the right credentials
because you're going to do something for
me and that's what is markers we have to
do we have to find the within what's in
it for me
for your for your prospects and your
your audience what was that acronym
with him what's in it for me w-i-i-f-m i
love it okay
i i have to dig a little bit deeper into
this concept because
you know at the end of the day you're
right we're working you know i could be
working 16 17 hours a day very
diligently on something that i think is
really special
but then in the one minute that i have
my audience's attention whether it's an
investor
a person that i'm selling to or another
employee that i want to on board to the
company
then then it doesn't work so what are
some of the pitfalls that you see people
make
that i should be avoiding on my
entrepreneurial journey
so i think one of the things that
happens is people get so passionate
about it that they want
because something makes sense to you it
should make sense to me as well
and and so you have to be careful and
also most cases we are not the target
audience for our product sometimes we
are
but sometimes the lens that we look
through the way we look
is not the way that other people are
going to see us and sometimes you have
something you're convinced is going to
be
used one way and it gets out there and
people say that's great let's use it
differently
so you have to be in communication with
the people that you want to or you think
are are really going to be benefiting
from what you're doing
and you have to have it be a two-way
conversation not a dialogue so it's not
like here's this here's this here's this
what do you think it's got to be tell me
what you want etc
now that being said people don't always
know what they want
no one said to steve jobs you need to do
itunes you need to do an iphone and ipad
he said wouldn't it be great if so no
one said to you know to to the uh the
folks from uber or
or um or airbnb we should do this so but
what they did is they looked at the
marketplace and
and uh and said gee you know hotels are
that's too expensive in there yucky what
if we did this um
nobody wants to drive in a taxi cab what
if we do that so
they looked at what was going on and
they said how do we make the situation
better
so it wasn't gee i have a great
technology let me go out and and
get it out to the world but how do i
change people's lives
in a way that they're going to really
appreciate it right so then what
what is your relationship with
entrepreneurs and executives
as they're framing their messaging and
as they're thinking about their they're
with them
so what i do um i you know and i work
with all kinds of companies i work with
large
silicon valley fortune 500 companies i
work with
uh you know professional services people
like real estate agents and
lawyers but i love working with
entrepreneurs
because they're so they're always so
passionate right and i love what they're
doing or you couldn't be an entrepreneur
and what i do is is try to help them
through that
initial passion where it's like gee this
is great to say
how do we get that message out to people
what does that really mean
and sometimes it can be a little painful
for them because you know you
it's like your child right so telling
your child is not dressed the way they
should be and you're saying no i address
them they're great
so yeah you know it's it's actually a
great baby that you have but we might
have to put them in a little bit
different outfit
to have them be you know the rest of the
world see how cute your kid is so
it's that kind of a thing um but it it's
great to be able to work with them
sometimes what i do is i work with with
technology companies
where they're very very smart people and
they have the right idea they have the
right um
you know the concept they know that
they're going to help their customer but
they're so focused on
the the uh the bells and whistles the
speeds and feeds
and we have to turn them to benefit so i
will take that language and
re re-kind of frame that in a way that
their audiences
oh now i get it now i understand what's
in it for me and why i should pay
attention to you
because if if you can't get my attention
and you've only got a very short period
of time
we have such short attention spans right
now
everybody you know i mean you think
about it your average commercial that
you might see on tv or on
you know on the internet is 10 15
seconds you know
there was a time when it was 30 60
seconds etc but
if you can't capture my attention in a
few seconds i'm gone
and so you've got to cut to the chase
very quickly and so how can we do that
so that's what i do is i help people
kind of take their messaging and frame
it and mold it in a way that people like
you and others can say oh
tell me more and then once i've got to
tell me more
now you can go out as an entrepreneur
and say hey try this or
here's what you need to know etc but if
you don't get my attention it doesn't
matter how good your product or service
is because i'm just
i'm just not there right is there a way
to validate this properly
without you know without going all out
on the on marketing spends and
and and sending this to the public so if
i go if i want to now go and test
this messaging and i sit down and say
okay michael i have a 20 character i
have a 20 word limit
uh to send to linda so that she she so
that she would be willing to
to buy my product and be on my show 20
minute leaders how do i get her
attention
how do i go about that process so here's
the thing
there's there's a big deal between
telling one person and telling a million
people
so what you do is you find a good target
audience
whether it's people you know or people
you're referred to etc and you say hey
i think you might be the right people
for this let me run this by you you know
what is it
does it resonate doesn't make sense and
sometimes they'll say yes and sometimes
they'll say no and sometimes they'll say
well
sort of but here's what it is that i
think makes sense
and then the other before you even do
that ask them you know hey
i've got this idea what do you think
would that make sense to you who would
buy this would you spend money on it
would that you know would you pay well
yeah you know or you know or maybe you
should talk to so and so
or not you know don't forget it i mean
one of the most important projects i did
a number of years ago because i also do
market research
was with an entrepreneur who had a
product in the consumer electronic space
and he was convinced that this was going
to be the next you know the next big
thing right
and so he hired us to do some research
and we went out and conducted focus
groups and we looked at this thing
inside outside backwards forwards
and people basically said i would never
buy this thing why
and so we had to sit him down and say
you know um
there really is not a market for your
product and he was kind of unhappy
because
we didn't just tell him his baby was
ugly he told him he shouldn't have the
baby at all right so
wow so he was sort of not real happy
anyway but i felt that we had saved him
millions of dollars
because had he not done that he would
have invested in this thing
and gone out and produced it he was
going to he had a factory in asia that
was going to make this stuff
he would have wound up with a with a
warehouse full of these things and
been out a lot of money and a lot of
time and effort so sometimes you know
you learn things you may not like
but it's really helpful to know so
through the lenses of marketing and
through
sort of coming in as a third party
independent and you're actually helping
sometimes uncover a lot of the
real you know the the the dirt of what's
happening right it's not just
that maybe the the mar the messaging is
not right but maybe that the product is
not right
and do you find that most people come
approach you when they have a problem
or when they're because it sounds
something like
like you're the type of person i would
go to when i realized that i'm not able
to do this myself
i'm trying and i'm not succeeding right
you know there's a couple things so
sometimes people come in because they
say hey we've got to a certain
point and we're stuck and very often you
know you get some people that like what
you have you get to hear and you want to
get to here
and you need to figure out how do you
break through so that could be it
but sometimes people come because they
say we've got this great thing we've got
this great product and i've got this
idea and we need your help to kind of
get it out there
and how do we make this thing be be
fantastic
um we haven't failed that we just not
sure how to get from from point a to
point b
uh and that's that's what i would say is
a maturity in an entrepreneur because
there are some entrepreneurs that say
i know everything i'm this is great i'm
convinced i have the the backing i have
this i have that
i know what the right message is and
sometimes they're right
and more often than not they kind of get
a little bit you know
pushed back because they think they know
and they haven't asked you know it's all
a one-way street they haven't had that
dialogue
right okay so talking a little bit about
consulting overall so before we dive
into the organization that you're
helping run the sac
i'd love to understand a little bit
better the role of a consultant
and why that is something that is
specifically interesting to you
so i spent a lot of time in in silicon
valley i worked for sun microsystems for
a number of years and
i left sun in the early 2000's and
people would send me jobs uh listings
hey you should do this you should do
that and i'd look at it and say i don't
want to work for them i don't want to do
that
so i sort of fell into consulting
because a friend of mine said well why
don't you go check this job out here and
i
i said i don't think that's right for me
but i did and i said well no no we don't
want to hire you but we'd love to bring
you in on a consulting project would you
be interested and i said
sure why not and so what i found that's
interesting about consulting is
you know one of the things i hate about
being in a company is you sit in
meetings and you have to go through all
the corporate stuff and the
political things as a consultant they
say we want you here to do something can
you help us with this
you come in you do it you provide
expertise
and then you leave you're not there for
all the other you know
ongoing things you're not trying to
climb the corporate ladder you're not
trying to to be a politically astute and
all that
uh and so it's fun and then the other
thing is i get to work with a lot of
different people
right so i get bored if i'm doing the
same thing all the time
so i can be working with five six seven
eight clients at the same time
not at the exact same moment but you
know after i finish with you i'm gonna
talk to this one and then i'm gonna talk
to that one
and so it mixes things up and it keeps
you sharp but a consultant a good
consultant comes in and brings their
expertise
and helps you um kind of understand how
to get to the next level
without making you dependent on them as
if you know
it's kind of like a crutch so it's not
that we're there to say hey you need to
keep hiring me and hiring me but
i'm here to help you solve a problem or
exploit an opportunity or whatever
and once i get you set then you go on
and we go on to something else and so
that's what i think
and that's the difference between a
consultant and a contractor we have in
silicon valley of a lot of contractors
which is great
they come in they get paid by the hour
they do what needs to be done they might
be there for years
that's perfectly fine consultants we
don't really
charge by the hour we charge by the
value we provide by the project
and we come in we provide this level of
expertise and then we leave
and we can help someone as a consultant
yourself do you bring in the expertise
that you have specifically in marketing
and messaging and through the book that
you've written the leverage to market
is that is that the main consulting that
you do
i do yeah so a lot of ideas around
marketing and everything from um
from strategy and branding and
positioning
i did a lot of work with channels and
partners in my time on the corporate
side so i work with
with people doing that marketing
intelligence which is like research
but then i also work with entrepreneurs
and small business people to say
let me coach you if you're having
trouble kind of figuring out where you
are and what you need to do
so sometimes i work with people just to
help them kind of
get their own ideas together and help
them move forward with that
and then the other thing i do is because
i'm creating a lot of content today
is not only do i create content for
clients but i also
edit other people's content so whether
that would be white papers or
promotional materials but i'm doing a
lot of book
either book proposals or book
manuscripts and in the midst of this
pandemic for whatever reason everybody's
gotten around to writing that project
they had put off for years
so i'm getting lots and lots of projects
coming in about people saying i finally
finished the book i need someone to to
look at it and again i can help
translate to the audience
but i'm also good at saying you know
that comma didn't appear where it should
be and you know yeah
you use the kind of a dangling
participle there so let's fix the
grammar
so all of those things i talk about
marketing above the noise
all those things that you know kind of
are there that aren't exactly right
they're all noise
and so when you want to get out and talk
to someone you want to get rid of all
the noise
it's like static right remember an
old-fashioned radio which may be before
your time but there was static right on
am
um you want to get rid of all the
statics so that i can hear you and we
can communicate directly
and so that's what i do is i help get
rid of all that static and all that
noise so you can reach your customers
more effectively
right no no and i think i think it's
it's a it's very funny that you
mentioned that everybody got around to
writing books i'm actually publishing a
book myself next week that i got
that i got that i got writing throughout
throughout the discovery times but i
want to make sure we also have enough
time to talk a little bit about
the about this group sac so so society
for
society association remind me to get the
exact name
society for the advancement of
consulting so um
alan weiss who's kind of the guru of uh
independent consulting
as my mentor and he had created this
association 17 years ago and he wanted
to give
independent consultants a way to get
together and kind of work with each
other
and it went on and on and on but he
didn't put a lot of time in it because
he had a lot of other things going on
so two and a half years ago he came to
me and a woman has become my business
partner in southern california and he
said
i i don't really have the time to put in
this would you take it over
and we said okay why not so we took it
over we blew away everything that was
old-fashioned and
labor intensive and took time on your
part made it all online
membership etc before there was a
pandemic we had gotten on we were early
zoom users so we knew before people
bell zoom and we said we're going to do
webinars and we we
you know what kind of value can we add
to our members so our motto is uh growth
by association so how do you grow by
being associated if you're an individual
person like an entrepreneur
how do you grow by by having the right
people around you so we do
we do webinars we do online workshops we
do all kinds of
um you know kind of uh we have special
interest groups like around people who
are interested in supply chain and
non-profits and technology
and we've grown the organization so that
we have um now we have members in 14
countries
and we have um so it's been a lot of fun
and people say to us wow that's this is
this has really been more than we ever
we
ever thought and they're across all
kinds of different consulting od
and technology and marketing and finance
and i.t and you name it
so it's all kinds of interesting things
and this year
actually this fall we normally have our
annual meeting every year in new york
city
and we had space on a hotel in new york
city and we moved it out to 2021
so we're doing it virtually and you know
here's the thing that's really
interesting
is you've got to as an entrepreneur
you've got to say here's where we are
and here's i'm going to make something
happen we said okay we can't be in new
york we're sorry about that we're sad
okay now we're done we have people in
all over the world we're going to have
an expanded day
where we're going to start very early in
the morning for us here in california in
europe or have sessions there
sessions middle of the day for north
america late in the day for pacific rim
so no matter where you are there will be
things happening in your time zone
we're going to be able to get experts
that won't come to new york and then
we're going to record everything on zoom
and archive it so you don't have to sit
michael from six in the morning till ten
at night
you pick what you want and you just
watch it whenever so
this is happening in october we've
already doubled the number of people who
would have come to new york and we still
have two months out
so that's what i mean about you see okay
you know the whole thing about lemons
and making lemonade
we can't be there in person how do we
make this even better and i think that's
what really makes a successful
entrepreneur
is you say hey this is not what i
thought i was getting into but given
where i am how do i take it and do the
best i can with it
wow i think that's just that's just
remarkable linda i want to
take this time to thank you for your
generosity
and for and for all the insights for
this but before we leave i have to ask
you my favorite question
which is three words that you would use
to describe yourself
three words i think number one is
creative i'm a writer i'm a musician etc
so i love creating things
number two is resourceful i take what's
given me and we turn it around do it we
can
and number three is determine you know
i'm not gonna you know you can't knock
me down i'll get back up
um and then figure out where we go from
here so creative resourceful determined
that's that's
me i love it i simply love it thank you
very very much
and this is wonderful all right take
care